tell me when i should read this
i am here good good
all right and representative you can go
ahead okay i'm going to read this uh
blurb that we have to guide us through
this meeting
it's required this is script for remote
meeting
as acting chair and vice chair of
criminal justice and public safety
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body has authorized to meet
electronically
please note that there is no physical
locations to observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting which was authorized
pursuant to the governor's emergency
order however in accordance with the
emergency order i am confirming
that we are a providing public access to
the meeting
by telephone and additional access
possibilities
by video or other electronic means
we are utilizing zoom for this
electronic meeting all members of the
committee and select staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously
during this meeting through the platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by clicking on the following
website address it's zoom dot u s slash
i nine four two three eight zero
six nine seven nine zero we're dialing
one of the following phone numbers
one three one two six two six
six seven nine nine or one nine
two nine two oh five six zero nine nine
b providing public notice of the of the
necessary information for asset for
accessing the meeting
we previously gave notice to the public
of the necessary information for
accessing the meeting
including how to access the meeting
using zoom or telephonically
this information is printed in the house
calendar
c providing a mechanism for the public
to alert the public body during the
meeting
if there are any problems if anybody has
a problem
call 271 3600
or email at capital h capital c capital
s
at ledge dot new hampshire dot u
s d adjoining the meeting of the
public is unable to access the meeting
we will adjourn if they can access it in
the event the public is unable to access
the meeting the
meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
i'd like to introduce the staffs during
the meeting assisting us
bradley greenland is the meeting host
additional staff provided providing
support are
jennifer iv and joel anderson
this is a work study session on bills
referred to the criminal justice and
public safety committee
for interim study an executive session
will follow
copies of the interim study bills have
been posted on the main
page of the general court website under
the heading
remote meetings please note that all
votes that are taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each member
member states their presence please also
state whether there is anyone in the
room
with you during the meeting which is
required under the right to know
law thank you linda i think you can take
attendance in yeah okay um
right here
um
[Music]
if someone's in with you
and all that good stuff
you home alone where are you talking to
me
yeah oh i'm sorry you're breaking up
i'm here and i'm alone oh i am okay
um i don't see her
i don't see her either oh hearn
clerk i'm here and i'm alone
off the back ear and alone
what nay here and my wife is in another
room
mused here and alone in the room murphy
beautiful here muted muted
you muted nancy
what am i still muted no good now
okay i'm i'm here and i'm home with
three remote students so
not in the same room but there may be
some noise from the background
newman i'm here at home
and my wife may enter the room
intermittently
radishes 9.
swim burn
welch
i know he's here yes
looks like he's muted still david you
muted
oh yeah i see okay
feels
green
testament you mute it
you mute it
your shoulders
wallace
[Music]
i am here i'm alone in my office my law
partner
is here but he has his own office my
door is locked
roy here hello to the room
and cushing is absent
so i should
so we have 11 present and i believe
that's a quorum
is that correct oh yes i believe so
okay
okay then we can proceed
oh yes you can okay there's just a
couple of things i wanted to say that um
renny should be coming in uh he's not
here because he's had some medical
issues this summer
and he has a medical appointment this
morning but he is
planning to jump in when he comes back
and that's one thing and the other thing
is
today what we're really doing is just
going over the retained bills
and making a decision about whether or
not we should
recommend future legislation and we're
not going into the
heart of the bills we're discussing them
in in a really
you know deep or meaningful way we're
just going to discuss
whether or not we recommend that
they have future legislation but
even if we say they shouldn't have
future legislation
um people can put in a bill so it
shouldn't be
very complicated and like
after after we talk briefly about the
bills i accept a motion to go into
executive session
okay any questions
no the first bill
of six is house bill 306 prohibiting
the destruction of sexual assault
evidence collection kits
does anybody have any comments on that
um i would just start off by saying that
unless and until we address the statute
of limitations
issue this would seem to be put in the
cart before the horse
if there's a statute of limitations on
the on the charge itself
mandating that the kit be kept
indefinitely
doesn't seem to make any sense and puts
an undue burden on the police
departments
to store rape kits indefinitely so
i think that this one might be a little
a little too early
well i think what happened uh in the
last two years that we've been looking
at this is that the department of
justice has been
doing an audit and we were waiting for
the results of that audit
and we're going to base our decision on
that
i think the next session people have to
see if that audit is finished and move
forward accordingly
there are other issues that would go
with that too like having a building to
for storage for
things they're kept indefinitely
representative rod do we have a sense of
when that audit results will we'll hear
those or
well no no especially with covid i don't
i don't know but i i think the next
session somebody
will want to look into that and pull the
information together
i i
are we supposed to raise our hand how do
we do this i guess if you could
raise your hand um virtually um
so we can keep track of um an order
it should be on the participant list and
you should be able to see raise hand
feature at the bottom
so you're recognized
thank you i understand listen if it's
out if any
offense is outside of the statute
limitations
the preservation of evidence for that
case is
i'm not sure what we're doing i i i'm
all for
storing the evidence for a longer period
of time
but there has to be a justification for
it
and you know i i was in support of
making the statute of limitations
for sexual assault cases
you know do not have one but at the same
time if it's
20 years time barred why would we ever
exert money
into stating that i don't think we need
an audit report to tell us that
whatever after limitations is it should
line up with how long we preserve the
evidence
at a minimum i think that's it you don't
want to be destroying it before
the stash limitations that wouldn't make
any sense if destruction of evidence
if that's counterproductive to what uh
courts police and
uh county attorneys do so
i think we can make the recommendation
that whatever the statute of limitations
is this is what you know what what they
would keep then there's also going to be
some digital evidence a lot of this
stuff is still stored the original is
not there but it will be the dna
evidence is going to be put
put into a database so there are civil
cases but at the same time
a individual the government of the state
should not be
required to preserve evidence in a civil
case that's a private
matter being brought privately
well the only thing we're deciding today
is whether
we recommend future legislation we don't
need to go into the guts of the
bill because you know we don't have
that that's not what we're here for and
this bill is sort of half-baked it
hasn't
come to nobody's come to any conclusion
and we don't need to really discuss the
the details of the bill because
we didn't do anything with the bill and
i think that
whoever whoever put in the sponsors are
going to want to put
pull it back in next next year so our
job is to say well we think
it should have future legislation or it
should not
that's all we're doing today
i think it's too soon to
pursue this bill we don't have the
storage facility there's a lot of
unanswered questions
and uh frankly i don't think it's ready
for
prime time beth can i
make a clarification about structures or
ask a question that might you might be
able to clarify
okay so we have this bill the audit's
not back
no everybody's uncertain about what the
time period is
so there are two things that can happen
to this bill someone can just submit it
and it's what's the difference between
somebody just submitting it
and we coming to the conclusion that
it's suitable
that it should be pursued to figure out
those details
does that have some bearing on on the
bill
in some some way no it has no bearing on
the bill
some but if a person wanted to put in
more legislation
they could say criminal justice uh
recommended that it
have you know future future legislation
and
that that's all this is just a way of
concluding our
our session um it has no bearing
on the bill it's so it's kind of
changing
and indoor it's kind of like an
endorsement if
of that type of bill or someone puts it
in yes
thank you and represent abroad
representative murphy has her hand up
you're recognized
muted muted
muted you're muted nancy
sorry i lost my whole screen um i i just
want to say i i understand that this is
merely more of a recommendation and
really doesn't speak to
the bill so much itself as whether or
not we think it's worthy of
reconsideration or or
submit the content is
worthy of of maybe a further legislation
i would support moving that forward that
that we
we support that um you know whether or
not it passes whether or not
we have the information at a time when
the bill is brought forward
um would be a whole different story and
would be evaluated then but
if we're looking at uh uh you know
talking about statute of limitations on
sexual assault itself
then i think this sort of would coincide
with that so
i would hate to to think we wouldn't
recommend something that would
um keep evidence when we would be
possibly considering um you know
reconsidering a
uh statute of limitations on the crime
so i i would support
moving it forward for future
considerations
thank you and
my understanding is that this uh what
we're doing today is really
not what's deciding to move these
particular bills forward the way they
are but it's more or less the
the concept of these bills so during the
hearing for this particular bill we did
hear
testimony that there are problems uh
with storing these materials
uh we also considered a a separate bill
a little bit later in the year that
would have removed the statute of
limitations on sexual assault crimes
we couldn't agree whether that should be
a
whether that should be a lifetime
removal of whether we should put a
number of years on it
but it seems pretty clear that
conceptually
we would want to save uh these rape kits
as uh
representative abbas was saying to line
up with uh whatever we decide in the
future so
conceptually i mean this seems to make
sense the devil's in the detail
representative murphy that uh it does
seem sense
it does seem to make sense to move it
forward
anybody else
all right um hearing no further
questions or comments uh
we'll move to the second bill
which is house bill do we make a
decision on this or is there a vote
after we're finished going over these
bills and
accept emotion because it's a work
session i
i remember now okay
uh the second bill is uh no it's not
that's not what it is um house bill 306
prohibiting oh i just didn't just lift
306.
okay we're on uh house bill 722
and act relative to the retail sale and
taxation of marijuana
uh on this bill
there's a ton of information here
scott wallace is not here today is that
correct
no he's not that's correct
i'm just looking at the committee report
um
apparently some of the major players and
stakeholders
uh for this bill and the other marijuana
bill that were going on
were not in were not heard
at the hearings and there is a
tremendous amount
of work and study that have gone on in
both these
bills and i i don't know i think we
probably should
think about recommending it for future
studies and so much work has already
been
done on them but all the stakeholders
have not
had the opportunity to participate but
um
i think the one thing that is always
left out
is the impact on our youth and i think
it's
a travesty to to implement a bill
like this without looking at the
implement
the implications in that case
but i think that's a good point and um
certainly that should be part of
whatever the next
legislature decides to do with it
and uh representative abbott has his
hands up yes
you recognize thank you
if i recall correctly there was a lot of
you know four hb 41 was different much
different than this
and the real difference was was the
taxation side of it so that's not
something that our committee
apparently supposed to deal with i don't
like the punt down the hall
but this one involved the sales tax
so i guess if you think that's worthy of
discussing the sales tax i fundamentally
don't think that's the way to go and i
would say that we
can this one doesn't mean we can the
issue of
uh legalization of cannabis but
this one particularly was not something
i was i was supportive of
it's a fairly comprehensive bill and
certainly the recommendations for other
areas to study in it children or taxes
should definitely be considered um so i
i would think that
the next legislature is going to deal
with that
marijuana is here to stay it's it's
legal in most of new england so um
if we can focus on
putting in a comprehensive bill in the
next session
uh i think that somebody will do that so
if you're happy with being another
massachusetts or another vermont
go for it
representative roy has his hand up yes
you're recognized
uh thank you madam chairman um i would
just
for the record um i
i endorsed the further study of this but
as far as the
criminal justice committee goes um
whether or not marijuana is here to stay
it is in fact
illegal in the entire united states
federally
so i i don't want us to send a message
that we're
flouting federal law but thing it's it's
legal
um regardless of what we decide to do
within the future
until it's changed federally it's still
a federal crime
right okay
are there any other comments i'm not
saying any other hands up
okay let's move on then
this is hb 1159
an act relative to cyber bullying cyber
stalking
and doxing of a public servant
um i think we'd like to hear from
the person most familiar with this
representative muse would you like to
speak to this bill
yes my my recommendation on this bill
would be that we not recommend it
uh for additional legislation um i think
that uh
part of the goal was for us to have a
a pretty good discussion about some of
the behaviors that take place online
um i think that there are real uh uh
first amendment issues uh
restricting the ability of people in the
media to be able to
uh to report on certain things uh
regardless of whether
we agree with what they report we
also have uh state laws
that do cover things like criminal
threatening um
and my recommendation would be that uh
that we not recommend this for
future legislation
thank you are there any other comments
and representative welsh has his hand up
you recognize representative welch yes
i'd like to just
to tell the camera i agree 100
with representative news okay and he
looks a little shocked but now i
i agree with him
how's the weather in san francisco not
bad
is anybody else uh have anything to add
to this
i'm not seeing any other hands raised
okay
moving right along
hb 1283 an act relative to
prohibiting the online disclosure of
personally identifiable
information
um representative news you wrote the
committee
report would you like to address this
one as well
yes i think that that this bill
basically falls into the same category
as uh
as the last one um we heard from people
uh from members of the new hampshire
press association during the
uh during the hearing for the bill
uh i think there were concerns about
uh abridging first amendment rights uh
to a large extent
uh uh people seem to be uh
you know seem to be uh acting
responsibly and
i think part of the issue with a bill
like this is
you have to cut uh you have to cut a
very very fine line
um to uh you know to avoid
you know actual arrangement of people's
first amendment rights
and and the rights of the media to
publish legitimate information
um uh
i think the privacy question is
something that we
we always are going to need to keep
looking at i think we'll probably
also like this again in the future um
i don't think that this is something
that i would support
moving forward in the next legislature
especially
knowing everything we're going to be
facing in the next legislature so
uh i would not uh not support uh
moving this forward
and representative welsh has his hand
yes uh again i agree with representative
muse
that's the nice choice now it's shocking
well no he makes a good point and i
agree with him
okay thank you does anybody else have
any comments i'm not seeing any more
hands
good this is i believe our last bill is
house bill 1663 an act relative to the
legalization
and regulation of canada and making
appropriations therefore
it's like like like the other marijuana
bill
this is more additional information and
ideas about marijuana um does anybody
have
any thoughts about it like
representative roy
we're basically trying to legalize a
federal issue
and you know i understand the the belief
that we ought to do this because
there are other states that do it
everybody's doing it why don't we do it
that's not a reason for passing a law
thank you are there any other comments
um i would just add that uh
going forward next year it looks like
we're gonna have a huge hole in the
state budget
uh we're gonna need to get creative uh
when it comes to
to filling that hole um so far it
doesn't look like we're going to be able
to fill it
with any money coming from the federal
government and some of the projections
that i've seen
are pretty terrifying so in the last
section we
legalized sports betting we've got some
revenue coming in there
this is an area that i think we need to
seriously
seriously look at and when it comes to
federal legislation
the federal legislation could very well
catch up to this
during our next session so to have
something like this in part
in progress given the fiscal condition
of the state uh and given
what could happen at the federal level
to me seems to be a pretty crude
thing to do i i would point out that
back in 2010
we were facing an 800 million dollar
budget
higher budget than we had money for and
the legislature found a way to get
around that
and we cut mental health we cut
education
uh we basically cut almost totally
indiscriminately
uh like recognizing the fact that we are
gonna have to make some cuts and i think
those are gonna be hard on everybody
um whatever we can do to bring uh
new revenue into the state um in a way
that um you know as much as we possibly
can
uh you know protects kids and protects
minors and protects people who shouldn't
have access to this stuff i think we
need to be doing it this is
this is an adult this is a thing that i
think adults in this state
have been advocating for years
it's something that other states do and
for us to keep
burying our heads in the sand uh when
every other state around us
has a law like this doesn't seem to make
a huge amount of sense
so again we're not here to debate the
merits of it but
that's just the way i feel
and representative looks like
representatives welsh newman and abbess
have their hands raised
representative welch
uh an area where i disagree with
representative news
i think that in the when you start
collecting revenue from a source
like marijuana which is going to affect
all our youth
and and many of our other citizens one
way or another
i just don't think it's a good thing to
do and i i
have supported the marijuana laws that
we have
i don't support making an industry
out of it thank you representative muse
i mean no was that representative um
because representatives newman
and then representative abbas okay
representative newman
you're recognized yeah i just have a
comment it's not on this bill i
i had another bill on our list 1586 i
just wonder if that's going to come up
next and i'll stop
thank you we're only doing four if i
remember right i believe 1586 is on that
list
i think it was on a list that i saw
previously i don't know whether we're
going to do that today or not just
wanted to bring it to your attention
thank you
so when when we have a moment i really
need to back up
because i couldn't find the sheet that
i got yesterday and i just realized that
in the work session
i actually have to put if we're
recommending future or not
and then also the person is
there's uh the first person to move that
recommendation and a second person and a
vote now that's the work session
and exactly i know i know what you're
going to say because i said the same
thing
the execution executive session
basically says the same thing but i'm
not sure why they sent me
both sheets look the same
well i i think we could have done the
executive session at the same time but
we
just decided not to and so that would be
um
that will happen after after this
session
okay and then uh that won't work
there'll only be uh one um
one uh committee
meeting there won't be a majority
minority report they'll just be the
majority report
and whoever makes that motion
should get that to us as soon as
possible
training okay so are we finished with
that bill
it looks like um representative abbott
also has his hand raised okay
representative
thank you you're recognized so
just again we're not going to get into
the merits of this one but
i agree that there are going to be some
revenue shortfalls
i thought that this one particularly
involved canada's being sold out of the
state
liquor stores or in the same fashion
so when i think what we want to do is
definitely put forward some the idea
that we want to talk about if we're
going to
legalize cannabis even something like
myself who's opposed it i always thought
that was
this was the best revenue option for the
state so i think that this
as a state we should put that forward to
study that if we're going to do it how
do we do it and
how do we maximize the state revenue
so okay thank you
is there anybody else not saying then
you got their hands raised
okay
and representative rob did you want to
do the work session for house bill 1586
as well
yes let's we'll move on to house bill
relative to the statute of limitations
for sexual assault
does anybody have a comment on that
we didn't we didn't we never got to a
point where we decided that um
there would be no statute of limitations
or we would increase it
so it's my feeling is that this is
something that we should
recommend for legislation next year it's
a continuation of the work that's been
done this
term what did the study can we come up
with
i'm sorry what did the funding committee
uh come up with
well if we put it into um interim study
but we
didn't study it because of the covet so
it probably needs further work with the
next session
okay and representatives murphy and
muse have their hands raised okay
representative murphy
oh thank you madam chair i absolutely
support
moving this legislation forward i think
it's very important
um to the many victims of sexual assault
a statute of limitations deprives them
of of um
you know given what we know of uh memory
and uh situational uh difficulties that
that victims have
um i absolutely think that that this is
a really important legislation it should
definitely be recommended to go forward
i would absolutely support that
thank you who else had their hand up
news thank you you recognized
representative muse
something that the county attorneys were
also very supportive of i think we had
three of them who actually showed up at
a public hearing which is i think the
most
i think i've ever seen show up at any
public hearing
so um i i think there's support
uh for this in the in the law
enforcement community and one of the
things that they told us that that
really stuck with me
was that um even though uh you know
things can happen to evidence and
witnesses
can pass away and things like that
in the end for them to be able to
prosecute one of these cases they still
have to be able to make a case
regardless of what the statute of
limitations is
i think during our debate we got a
little bit wrapped around the axle
around should it
should it be unlimited or should we try
to put
a 15-year cap or 20-year 25-year cap and
i think those were some of the things
we were going to try to study but
i think definitely in the next session
of the legislature
doing something with this should should
be a priority for the reasons that
representative murphy
though articulately stated
just a few minutes ago
any other comments thank you uh
representative abbas has his hand up
representative you're recognized thank
you
representative murphy and representative
muse took all the good material but
i agree with what they have to say and i
i just want
you know for what we recommend i mean
did we just give a thumbs up thumbs down
i think
the biggest opposition we had this bill
had was
you know he said she said 40 years later
and i get that
and we could always consider when
there's physical evidence available
if or if it's stored electronically that
doesn't really matter how old it is
i mean the reason why you have sol is
when evidence and witnesses go
disappeared pass away or evidently go
stale
but i think we can and the digital age
that we're in that's not
as much of a problem it is it was
20 30 years ago
thank you is there anybody else who'd
like to comment on this
not seeing any other hands raised okay
i think that concludes our work session
um so i would entertain a motion to go
into
a executive session
you'd have to vote on that motion as
well
um am i seconding the motion i seconded
it
but then the first one was welch
yes correct okay yeah
and representative rudd um i understand
that you'd have to vote on that to go
into the executive session as well
yes or you could declare that you're
going to executive session
i'm going to i'm going to take up let's
take up executive session i think it's
been
motion's been made and seconded
yes yes so we can then move into
executive session
i have a question uh are there any
is anybody see the public on on the
line at this time and do they have
anything to say
an executive session the public is not
invited
too prior to this i
i'm sorry i'm a little bit
but i'm assuming they had no comment or
word on or what
well no nobody raised their hand right
that's not true it looks like we um have
someone in attendees that does have
their hand raised at the moment
well now we've already made a and
seconded um motion to go into executive
session so how does that work
yeah we're already in the executive
session that we have in order to take
comments now
is it since we're in the executive
session then all right
i have a question we're in the voting
mode and it's
inappropriate to do anything unless we
finish what was started we got a motion
and a second
and we should vote yeah and that that's
the correct representative well she
would need to vote on that motion
to go into executive session we need a
roll call
we actually already did but we you're
right we do need a roll call
for everything sorry and representative
looks like representatives newman and
abbott have their hand raised as well
can you guys just raise your hand like
that and then she can see
are we voting and representative
representatives there's newman and abbas
have their hands raised
i thought we were still in the comment
period before the vote maybe
no no we're already in voting mode we're
not commenting
anymore we're taking a roll call
to see if people want to go into
executive session
so if the clerk would start the roll
call again
we can get through that
right yes
[Music]
clerk yes out the back yes
wouldn't
yes murphy yes
newman yes where is
yes wallace out
abbas no
and roy yes
let's find the one so
okay thank you
so we'll start with um the first bill
should we recommend for future
legislation
or not house bill 306 prohibiting the
destruction of sexual assault evidence
collection kits
that would be a roll call vote
do we need a motion yes you need a
motion
i'll make a motion to um
recommend for future legislation
representative newman has his hand
raised
representatives yeah i just have a
question
yes
what what is your question yeah i think
i i
our last vote was to go into an
executive session was that correct
yes okay thank you i was confused i'll
uh
stop now
okay so i made a motion it was second to
go
into uh to recommend for future
legislation
i didn't get the second afterbite
thank you
okay just let you know
smelly
nope
so are we are we doing a
yeah we need to do a roll call vote
yeah the most the most the motion is
the motion is to recommend for future
legislation
um hospital 306. yep
okay you ready and representative
boardney has his hand raised
we recommend this to go forward we
should make sure there's a physical note
on it because
uh either state our local law
enforcement have
you taken that
all right that would be
something that you deal with in the next
session
so can we start the boat
right yes
interlock is absent
yes yes
newman yes radishes
and swinburne absent watch
no
feels absent green
absinthe testament no
wallace absent abbas
yes roy
no
that's three
eight three
okay i'll be writing the committee
report for that
the next uh the next bill is house bill
relative to the retail sale and taxation
of
marijuana
would anybody like to make a motion
all right you have to wait for the clerk
so which bill we are now
house bill 722 relative to the retail
sale
and taxation of marijuana
okay representative
muse do you want to make a motion
i'm sure i will uh i'd recommend this
for future legislation
okay uh will you take a roll call vote
on this looks like um
representative murphy has her hands
raised all right yes represent murphy
you're
recognized muted i just got a second
oh okay okay
okay rod yes
pantalakas absent o'haran absent
clerk yes out the back yes
morton i yeah news
yes murphy yes
newman yes that is just not an absence
watch no
feel absent green absent
testament i'm sorry
no wallace
absent abbas
no roy no
seven to four
okay
okay uh the next bill is house bill 1159
relative to cyber bullying
cyber stalking and doxxing of a public
servant
would anybody like to make a
recommendation
i would like to make a motion that we
that we
do not recommend this bill for future
legislation
all right who's who was number one muse
i think i was but that's all right oh
so is it um welch and muse
yep okay okay okay
well to you right
this is not for future legislation is
the motion
before us
11 59 correct
um okay i'm ready if you are 11 59.
yep right
yes
clerk yes after back yes
yes murphy yes
newman yes
welch yes
estimate yes
wallace fox forgot absent
abbas yes
and why yes
eleven zero
uh david would you send me something on
this for the
committee report please
david muser david welch
all right then i need to change that so
who's going to do it
so i'll know
um i i can do it i have a i have a blur
uh prepared all right so i'll change
that
and make muse first okay
okay
okay the next bill is hb 1283 relative
to prohibiting the online disclosure of
personally identifiable
information
[Music]
and nobody wants to write reports and
represented
represent a muse yes
i would like to make a motion that we do
not recommend this bill
for future legislation all right
oh okay who's on the second then we all
said second at the same time
harriet catherine
okay
right yes
clerk yes off the back yes
yes muse yes
murphy yes no man
no man
you need it
yes
welch yes
testament yes
abbott
yes why
yes
11-0
okay
all right um the next bill which i put
out of order
before is house bill 1586
relative to the statute of limitations
for sexual
assault i would make a recommendation
that it be referred for future
legislation
second second
so it's a rod and murphy
is that right yes
okay
right yes
clerk says yes opted back yes
wouldn't they yeah news
yes murphy yes
newman yes
welch yes
testament yes
[Music]
habits yes
no ten
one
uh
ready when you are is that it
okay
[Music]
where where are we we're on house bill
of 1663.
okay um i recommend for future
legislation
second second
that's who's that afterwards
okay thank you and we have a roll call
right yes
clerk is yes out the back yes
news
is he muted yeah sorry
murphy yes newman
yes
welch no
testament no
abbas
no roy
no
7-4
okay i i believe that's it
yes and that was recommended for future
legislation right
yes yeah okay i forgot to check it after
that
okay so
uh representative muse uh if you could
give me a little report on
future legislation for 722
and also for 11 59
and sorry 1283.
[Music]
how soon do you need those ben
as soon as you can get them okay
[Laughter]
that's cool i mean i mean uh right now i
mean right now
okay i'll start working on them as soon
as we're over
okay thank you i
i think that concludes our business for
today
so um people can go off to archery or
the beach or
whatever good things we have for the
rest of the day
and this tomorrow will be my last day
with the legislature
and i want to say what a pleasure it's
been working with all of you
and it's been an awful lot of fun so
i guess we'll all see each other
tomorrow and um wish you all
good luck in your thank you
did you make a mention earlier of an
executive session
we just had the executives okay
um never mind forgetting i was thinking
of something else a different type of
session thank you oh because i'm i'm
floating in an alternative universe
we did we did we did our work today we
did good
so good luck to everybody in your races
who's running
and um i'll see you all tomorrow
take care thank you thank you beth
thank you